let's dig into the big news of late last
week in the weekend we had been
expecting a house vote last week for the
repeal and replacement of Obamacare with
the American Health Care Act the vote
did not have a chance of passing and
thus it was pulled Donald Trump
reportedly told Paul Ryan to pull it or
maybe it was Ryan's decision to pull it
depending on who you believe doesn't
really matter
it's another embarrassment for the Trump
administration and the Republican
Congress so far let's start with the
politics of it more than seven years and
more than 60 House votes to repeal
Obamacare when it had no chance because
Obama would have vetoed it had the
repeal passed the Senate years to come
up with a plan and Republicans failed 64
days into Trump's presidency to do what
they all campaigned on to repeal the
Affordable Care Act
countless promises from Trump to repeal
it quickly and immediately more on that
later and another failure is anybody
really surprised that all along when
Republicans talked about repealing and
replacing Obamacare they never had a
plan are you surprised by that Pat it
took him seven years and they couldn't
come up with anything and they said that
it was important that we repealed
Obamacare because the popularity of that
was maybe in the 40s forty five percent
or so yeah the popularity of the
American Health Care Act their bill was
only 17% far worse not to mention that
the provisions of Obamacare are very
popular and that's why often times if
you say what do you think about
political thing one people will say yeah
you know whatever 4045 percent if you
say what do you think about this
provision what do you think about that
provision what do you think about this
other provision which are of course what
make up that political policy you have
very very high support that's what's
going on with Obamacare right now this
new plan as Pat mentioned is one that
very few people liked that doesn't mean
Obamacare is secure nor perfect nor that
Republicans now like it but clearly they
are realizing that if you repeal
Obamacare it will have consequences and
those consequences might not be good
which gets us into the health care
aspect of this all Affordable Care Act
provisions except for the mandate that
everybody have health insurance our
very popular you need the mandate to
make the whole thing affordable though
you really can't have the stuff people
like without the mandate and this has to
do with risk pools and self selection
bias if you allow only the people who
want health insurance to have health
insurance you were going to create a
self selection bias where where you will
see people who most need insurance much
more likely to actually buy insurance
and that's going to make it more
expensive there's a car insurance
example which is if you don't make car
insurance mandatory only people who
believe that they are more likely to
have to file claims either for more
erratic driving or because they speed
more often or because they drive more
miles you will have an insured group
that in total their mean driving risk is
higher that means you have to charge
more for insurance this is just sort of
basic math Pat that I think a lot of
people don't get in some Republicans
pretend not to get even though they do
which is you need everybody to be
covered in order to keep prices lower
than they would otherwise be that's how
it works
in the context of the for-profit health
industry oh we had single-payer we
wouldn't need a mandate it would just
come out of your taxes and that's what I
get to next this Obamacare is a right
wing plan okay it's a right wing plan in
that it was suggested in the 90s by
right-wing think tanks it's a right wing
plan in that the only really worthwhile
changes to be made are liberal changes
public option single-payer expanding you
know Medicare for all universal coverage
people would lose coverage and premiums
would go up in the short-term ten years
from now supposedly they'd be lower
under the aah a but we know that our
predictive ability for something so
massive ten years out is really pretty
minimal it failed because it deserved to
fail and it's exposing that Republicans
are the incompetent party we've known
them to be but it should also expose
that the changes to be made are changes
that should move us to the left not to
the right and we're gonna be dealing
with that more and I also want to deal
with Donald Trump's lies about the
failure of the American Health Care Act